mais
la vie de bénédicte mature et a changé à
jamais jeudi soir deux voilà propulsée
sous les projecteurs de la plus
prestigieuse ligue de basketball du
monde c'est toujours mon rêve de jouer
en nba et je sais que mon frère qui au
paradis ce moment est avec moi cette
période alors c'est quelque chose que
nous sommes excités peau est vraiment à
12 ans matures et à berne son frère
heurter à mort par une voiture alors
qu'il circulait à vélo après un passage
à l'académie de la m lié au mexique il a
suivi les traces de sa soeur aînée au
basketball universitaire américain
deux saisons passées en arizona plus
tard il rejoint trois montréalais dans
l'ain billets à la différence que google
store crise boucher etc mbls n'ont
jamais été repêché avec les autres
joueurs de montréal et autres grands
partenariats rebelles il ya eu des
rapports je pense tout le monde l'a vu
pris 115 son casque est donné la main au
cul mais cela
pour pour lui pour toute notre
communauté de montréal n'a pas ce que
vous savez entre autres bénédicte et un
jeune qui a été très soutenue par la
communauté entre autres par son école
adélard desrosiers à montréal nord
mathieu est devenu un exemple et une
inspiration pour les jeunes et aussi
pour les moins jeunes ces jeunes-là qui
rêve d'être juif qui rêvent 12,2 deux
dates à la nba 6 6 6 1 step pour eux
c'est ccx eeyou chc bon en gros ça
montre qu'à montréal il ya du talent
riad potentiel pic il faudrait peut-être
investir un peu plus là dedans c'est
quelqu'un que tu fais avec nous que tu
viennes montréal aussi ont foulé devenu
difficile mais millions maintenant au
cours des prochaines semaines
mathurin devrait signer un contrat de
quatre ans qui lui rapportera environ 25
millions $ et ce n'est peut-être que le
début il s'y attendait et radio canada
montréal